fletcher era appena uscito da una
picchiata da oltre 2000 metri e
sfrecciava pochi palmi dalla spiaggia
quando un giovane uccello vanno
direttamente sulla sua traiettoria
fletcher a effettuare una fulminea
virata sulla sinistra e andò a
schiantarsi a 200 miglia l'ora contro un
masso di granito ci fu un cazzo
accecante un nero scoppio di terrore e
stupore è un istante dopo e gli pagava
la deriva di uno strano cielo in memore
quella roccia per lui fu la soglia
attraverso cui si accede in un diverso
mondo
già da giada era bloccata sull'orlo di
un piccolo avvallamento tornare verso di
lei e mi disse che aveva paura a
scendere da lì le dissi non preoccuparti
rimane lì io e tua mamma ci allontaniamo
un po andiamo sulle rive lì sulle rive
del lago speravo che la voglia di stare
con noi facesse superare il piccolo
ostacolo o che almeno la paura di
rimanere da sola sarebbe stata più
grande nella paura del declivio lei
chiama sua mamma che l'ha presa in
braccio e la porta dall'altra parte
successivamente mi trovai a fronteggiare
un problema simile con la paura
dell'acqua di mio nipote
stavolta però invece di buttarmi in mare
e lasciarlo solo sulla spiaggia
mi fermai lì con lui per cercare di
capire come era fatta la sua paura ed
elaborare una strategia nuova guardando
lo capì che era come paralizzato di
fronte a un sentimento che lo metteva a
disagio mi figura e la sua paura come
l'uomo nero il babau è una brutta
sensazione di freddo vuoto da qui
filippo voleva solo scappare una paura
maggiore non avrebbe fatto altro che
accrescere la sua confusione
l'ipotesi di un futuro premio non
funzionava perché la paura è come uno
schermo nero ti toglie l'orizzonte
a seguito di questi due avvenimenti
riuscì a definire meglio il mio coraggio
che non è assenza di paura quanto
confidenza con la paura abitudine a un
sentimento che di primo acchito ti porta
a scappare ea girare la testa dall'altra
parte per non provarlo per non vederlo
neanche quindi riprendendo la metafora
dell'uomo nero
posso dire che a forza di frequentarlo
imparato a conoscerlo e non è poi così
nero non è poi così cattivo e
soprattutto quando sei riuscito a
fermarmi ad ascoltarlo ha avuto qualcosa
da dirmi quando cammino sul cavo non è
questione di opporsi o combattere la
paura sarebbe un combattimento ho perso
in partenza che toglierebbe energia
concentrazione alla mia camminata
io penso più alla questione di integrare
la paura di permettermi di sentirla
alla fine come mettere un nuovo attrezzo
nella valigetta degli utensili e io lo
uso per stare attento per essere
consapevole vigile
durante le mie durante le mie
passeggiate quando attraversa gli appena
billy tra i con una valle tra il colle
dipende il colle di billy tirava molto
vento e dovrai mi trovai affrontare il
problema del vento e logisti un po come
la paura considerando vento e paura 2
forza qui non potevo oppormi quindi
cercai di integrare il vento nel mio
essere
durante la camminata per qualche secondo
riuscì a essere veramente vento e capii
che possiamo essere qualsiasi cosa e lo
sto parlando di fare questo quello
perché a 90 metri di altezza su un cavo
da 14 mm
non puoi fare molte cose dovessero
andare avanti sto parlando della libertà
da da ogni identificazione da ogni
costrizione dal passato dal futuro e
libertà della nostra identità per
guadagnare leicester è assoluto quindi
quando ora mi chiedono cosa prova sul
cavo di solito rispondevo paura e
solitudine o raggiungo anche libertà
un'altra parola che mi piace usare
riguarda le mie camminate la parola
compromettersi nel senso inglese di non
solo di mettersi in una situazione ma
mettervi sì con coraggio completamente e
quando sono sul cavo mischi un po i due
sensi della parola italiana di
compromettersi perché da un lato
fisicamente mi metto a rischio ma
dall'altro antologicamente tutto il mio
essere coincide con il mio fare è vivo
dei momenti di secondo me di vera
autenticità sul cavo la situazione è
talmente estrema è talmente pericolosa
che neanche una piccola parte di me può
essere da un'altra parte devo essere
esattamente tutto dove sono quindi uso
questo mio coraggio abitudine la paura
per mettere a rischio mio piccolo io per
essere tutto senza mezzi termini in
quello che faccio e gioco un po la
scommessa di pascal quindi mi gioco una
posta finita per una vincita infinita e
come dice pascal se vincete vincere
tutto se guardate non perdete nulla 15
vita a scommettere senza timore e questa
scommessa per me avviene proprio nel
momento del primo passo sul cavo perché
quel momento prendo la decisione
per quanto temporalmente limitata però
definitiva di sospendermi dopodiché non
avrò altre possibilità di scegliere avrò
un'unica strada non ci saranno bv per
questo mi fanno molto paura alle gru i
palazzi o terrazzi che magari si
avvicinano al cavo mentre cammino perché
in questi luoghi in questi oggetti si
cela un tranello la possibilità di una
sorta se mi fermassi durante la
camminata non so se riuscirei a
riprendere la decisione di sospenderne
soprattutto dopo che so già cosa mi
aspetta la scelta della sospensione
richiede coraggio ma paga con
l'autenticità e con la felicità
dell'essere quindi per essere felici ci
va coraggio sia per cercare la felicità
perché mettersi in cerca di qualcosa
come ogni partenza richiede un piccolo
sacrificio di una parte di noi quella
parte che la paura ci fa guardare e ci
fa credere importante mentre invece solo
la zavorra che ci tiene fermi a terra
dopodiché raggiunta questa felicità ci
va coraggio per mantenerla tutti i
giorni quotidianamente perché una cosa
19 minuti di sospensione sul cavo una
cosa è la lotta quotidiana contro le
banalità a controllare i problemi
quotidiani
quindi vorrei avere ancora più coraggio
per poter scegliere ogni mattina di
guardare lontano di morire nel finito
per rinascere nell'infinito dopodiché
scoperta questa possibilità scoperte che
possiamo essere infinito diventa nostro
dovere estero lottare tutti i giorni per
essere felici e per trovare nella nostra
strada avrà la felicità il gabbiano
jonathan livingston era si distingueva
dagli altri gabbiani perché a differenza
degli altri non aveva paura di imparare
imparare quindi anche cercare e scoprire
la nostra strada e percorrere anche se
una strada pericolosa tanto incontreremo
il babau e ne faremo un buon compagno di
viaggio ci seguirà coraggio per trovare
le strade dove nessuno le vede e per
urlare la nostra felicità contro il
brusio del mondo quindi non posso
augurarci che le nostre strade siano
hardware ci permettono di correre rischi
anzi ci obblighino a camminare con tutto
il nostro essere in equilibrio sul
baratro
noi coraggiosamente col cuore ci
metteremo a rischio senza esitazione
senza ripensamenti
passo dopo passo dopo la paura dopo la
concentrazione che ci priverà di alcuni
sentimenti
esploreremo nella gioia ora però
smettetela di ascoltarmi io sono solo un
altro odioso dito che vi indica dove la
vostra felicità non state zitti urlate
più forte di me la vostra autenticità
alzatevi andate a cercare la vostra
strada senza sapere dove vi porta
compromette tesi su di essa saltate nel
buio e decidete ciò che fate